[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the vr betting drop zone that
is right we are live in the bleacher
report app and we've teamed up with
draftkings to give you a first look at
the biggest super bowl props that's
right i'm connor rogers alongside greg
ivory you may know us as the regular
squad ride duo the crew that talks to
you every sundays we're looking for
anytime touchdown scores we have fun
greg gives stuff away and man we have a
good time but it's super bowl week so
we've gone all out we need a little help
we need a little backup we need
something to make this extra special so
we've called in
a good friend an nfl legend a super bowl
champion there he is a keep to leave
joining us today keith what's up man how
you feeling
what's up guys hey it's super bowl week
man let's get it
that's right let's get it get it a keep
i'll throw one at you right away we're
coming off two conference championships
one surprising one maybe not i let's
let's get into it are you surprised the
bengals are here right now that we're
talking about the cincinnati bengals
i am man i am uh and now first let me
say this i i think
the nfl is the most competitive it's
been
since i've been a part of it man that's
you know that's 12 that's played 12 14
15 years
so i'm kind of surprised the bengals
here but i did expect the chiefs to win
so man i i gotta say i'm surprised if i
went to win to kansas city and beat them
boys
yeah that's right now it doesn't matter
if you are riding with the rams or you
riding with those bengals for the upset
the most fun way to make money is to bet
on as many props as you can even if
you're just out here sprinkling a few
bucks here and there having fun get in
on those props and we're about to give
you a first look at 40. that is right
you heard me 40 favorite draftkings big
game props and greg
with 40 props comes great responsibility
and great giveaways what do you got for
him today
connor what aren't we giving away
we got custom odds boosts from our
friends over there at draftking shouts
out to them over a thousand connor over
a thousand dk dollars jerseys of course
hoodies and an iphone 13.
keith i don't even got an iphone 13 you
got one bro
austin ain't going to the store yet bro
man i mean we i got to get to the store
apparently i got to get to the snow they
got the 13s out but the producers
telling me in my ear to give out
something right now so i'm in the
comments i'm in the comments this right
here is the handy dandy ipad for the
people that do not know this is how you
get your hoodies and comments dk dollars
this is how you get it right here in
this ipad and i'm in here looking for a
take and i see br bedding in the
comments
shout out to br betting but i see
freda fletcher frieda felcher 78 says
34 30 bengals gave us a prediction of
the game and also
[Music]
a lot of people haven't been saying the
bengals but i like what they did they
threw a curveball at so shout out to you
you are walking away with the jersey of
your choice
the handy dandy ipad man it's like going
to the bank at this point especially
tonight and if that isn't enough for you
be sure to check out draftkings for a
chance to win a 3
million dollar bet that is right a 3
million bet draftkings is giving out up
to 10 million dollars in free bets this
week opt in by 2 p.m eastern on big game
sunday and you can win a free bet of
anywhere from 10
to a million dollars check out
draftkings.com for official rules all
right we got a lot of props to talk
let's get right into it let's dive in
let's look at these quick hitters maybe
you're watching the super bowl with a
friend and you owe him some money and
you owe it to him by halftime well you
got to get in on the quick hitters
action let's take a look at these props
here we're talking coin toss we're
talking opening kick a touch back first
offensive play from scrimmage we got
first quarter total points under seven
and a half over seven and a half this
board is loaded but fellas i'm looking
at that last category first touchdown
this is what we do over here at br
betting we are looking for touchdown
scores we are looking for the first
touchdown score of the game cooper cup
at the top of the board joe mixon cam
akers this is juicy odds in this
territory with odell beckham at plus 900
t higgins couple more pass catching
tight ends with higbee right there as
well so
greg
we got the board already but now we need
the people right now we need the
people's opinion let them know what you
need and how they can win some of these
giveaways
hey everybody that is watching everybody
that's in the comments listen up and
listen up closely i need everybody to
use your fingers use those twitter
fingers instagram fingers bleacher
report fingers whatever you want to call
them to get in the comments and let us
know who is scoring the first touchdown
in the big game on sunday i'm giving
away a hoodie and i'm also giving away a
jersey connor
you'd love to see it man you'd love to
see it so stick around this is not the
time to leave you've got the phone
giveaway at the end of the show jerseys
dk dollars you know the deal right now
akib we know these we know these damn
receivers they love the spotlight they
love the celebration they love getting
in the early action it's your job to
shut them down do you have any favorites
amongst this group for first touchdown
score
oh
so i'm looking at this list
i i keep looking at higbee i don't know
if that knee gonna be right i don't know
how healthy i don't know what the
practice has been like
i like the doubles to go to odell cooper
cup
chase definitely gonna get it so i i
keep going to these running backs
i'm gonna go cam acres man i like the
plus 750 i'm gonna go cam makers to get
the first first teddy of the game
akiba i would never expect you to give a
wide receiver some love for that first
touchdown i like hammaker's plus 750.
you know what then i'll do it i'm gonna
roll with odell beckham here right i
think everybody's got the spotlight on
cooper cup and he's earned that there's
a lot of spotlight on jamar chase and
future offensive rookie of the year he's
earned that but odell has been shining
since he got to los angeles he is at his
best when those lights are bright and i
think odell is going to put on something
special for the super bowl in this game
he might have the more favorable matchup
so odell plus 900. greg where are you
going you rolling with these rams picks
over here you got something else in
store
i see rams to my left i see rams to my
right
he talked about ikea talked about
running backs and i like that i mean he
is a defensive le nfl legend so he knows
his football so i'm going to piggyback
on the key but i'm not going to take
acres i'm not going to take him acres
i'm taking my man from the bay area
himself joe mixon hey
i need him the ball man go go score the
touchdown first it's plus 750.
i like that but let me hop into these
comments let me hop into these comments
keep let me hop into these comments
connor
uh
everybody's everybody's still in the
comments giving us prediction on what on
what the score is going to be but i also
said i also see a deal preet in the
comments deal preet 1 says greg lock up
t higgins to score first so shout out to
you deal preet you are walking away with
a hoodie connor they're telling me i
need to give away a jersey and listen
here i see
eric willpower he says joe mixing greg
la gives up a lot of red zone runs one
big play could get the bengals close for
a run touchdown i like that there he is
william uh epic will power you are
walking away with a jersey of your
choice a a connor you see what he did he
took my pick and then he got a jersey so
you know
how things goes around here
yeah yeah exactly gotta be smart exactly
the comments are on to the man with the
giveaways they know that there's gonna
be a lot of greg love in the comments
today and if you've been following us
all year you know that and if you've
been following us all year you also know
our favorite quick hitter is the no
score first drive that's what we are
looking at through draftkings all year
every monday night football that's what
we do i got something special this year
you see it right there points on the
first drive a field goal a touchdown it
doesn't matter boosted from plus 150 to
plus 220 so get in on that no score
first drive action
keeb let's find out from you these teams
coming in hot is the super bowl going to
be a shootout early on or is this going
to be a feeling out processing slow
[Music]
i think my man aki muted himself but
that is okay
he doesn't want to give away the good
stuff just yeah
what i think he was going to say uh but
i get my pick connor because i know the
people the people want to know
i'm going with no score first drive i'm
going with no score first drive i mean
defenses wins championships i think
these defenses are going to come out you
know what i'm saying i think they're
going to try to make a statement early
and we saw last week we saw last week
the rams didn't score in the first
possession and the bengals didn't score
in the first possession so i'm rocking
with no man i'm rocking with no and i
i hope it keeps rocking with me connor
which way are you riding
yeah i'm with you greg for real i'm with
you all the way i'm going with no points
here i think that
when you look at it these are oh we got
to keep back i hear him i'm going no
points greg is going no points i hear a
keeb we're going to get him back on
because we want to know what he's got so
i hear he's back i'm back my back
welcome out there
no you're not you're good
yeah i'm definitely going no i don't
think they're coming out scoring man i
think i think the the defense gonna come
out hot
both both offenses got to kind of you
know fill out the defense see how they
playing i see where jalen is and i'm
saying see where how they're gonna use
them i'd like both these to come out and
get a stop first drive
all right so no points on the first
drive across the board me greg
we're expecting
nothing all right before we move on to
the player props we're gonna talk about
this coin toss pick a little bit of hot
topic of the super bowl but greg
it's time you sit on a stack over there
you got some dk dollars to give away let
them know how they can get in on this
action
hey connor this year we are going all in
on the coin toss yes the coin talks so i
need everybody to get in the comments
and tell us whether you think
it's gonna be heads or tails if your
pick matches my man a keep to leaves you
yes you can be walking away with 250 dk
dollars and connor we say this every
time we give away dk dollars
please parlay that 250 please parlay the
250 so you can bubble
it up more and more but uh
yeah y'all got to have the same same
thing as my mana key but then y'all can
be walking away with the 250
all right before we get to that and greg
i know you're going gonna be watching
these comments closely check out these
coin toss picks from our friends over at
draftkings
in a heads or tail situation calling
heads is a fireball offense i have a big
head i know about big heads they weigh
more it's science it's first grade stuff
i'm a tails guy i always go tail
whenever i got to call the coin toss
it was
tails never fail i feel like i've been
lifting up a lot of tickets so we're
going the opposite way heads on the coin
toss and i'm also taking heads to the
coin toss fail i'm going heads
you get it because that's my hand let's
go ahead
don't get fired keep it simple call
tales game blouses make sure you've been
on the big game jacket
all right you heard it from draftkings
even split three going with heads three
going with tails
i keep how about you decide tails never
fails or are you rolling with heads on
this one
tails never fails baby and i i'm not 100
sure but i think in this kansas city
this kansas city little situation we
just had
i think kansas city pig pigtails and
then uh
the bangles or whatever over time the
bengals lost but they pick heads
i'm going all right you heard it from
here akib is going with tails never
fails great where are the comments going
right now before you give away those dk
dollars
connor let me hop into these uh comments
right here
and see what they are talking about
i'm giving away some dk dollars um so
um i want to make sure i give it away to
the right person okay jg276 says tails
you already know shouts out to you jg276
you walk away with a hoodie uh spicy
angel is also in the common sense tales
every day
shout out to you spicy angel
you are walking away with the hoodie but
hold on
let me give out this let me give out
this
250 dk dollars and i'm gonna give it out
to king kong right here king kong 22.
tales never fails my man keeps said that
he literally just said it my man
commented that so therefore you are
walking away with the 250dk
all right and we got a lot more from
where that came from so stick around if
you want to get in on the dk dollars
action and we got a lot to give away so
let's keep this thing moving we're
looking at player props one of the most
favorite markets of the entire super
bowl we got the quarterback head-to-head
at the top for passing yards running
back head-to-head at the top for rushing
yards my favorite right there the wide
receivers cooper cup against jamar chase
for receiving yards so this board
absolutely loaded fellas akeeb let's
start with you who are you taking on
this wide receiver head-to-head prop
cooper cup who had a phenomenal year or
the pending offensive rookie of the year
in jamar chase
uh both of these guys top receivers man
two great receivers uh but i feel like
the rams
got a guy who can contain or maybe stop
we'll see him saying ask me i'm gonna
say he could stop him but he could they
got a guy right with a name who got a
star around his his name on the madden
they got a guy who could tank who could
contain chase i don't know if cincinnati
got a guy who could stop cup and i like
him to come out and play a lot of zone
until the rams show him you can't beat
his plans on when you play zone cooper
cup go crazy i'm wrong with cooper cup
all right akeeb is riding with cooper
cup right there on the head to head for
most receiving yards
all right let's keep it moving let's
keep it moving here we got mvp let's see
the mvp odds board for the super bowl we
know the quarterback
always sit at the top of this matt
stafford oh here it is money new plus
money plus a hundred joe burrow plus 225
and this is when the fun gets started we
got cooper cup plus 600 a d plus 1600
there's jamar chase and odell beckham
and then it gets really off the rails
with the running backs and cam akers and
joe mixon so greg i know that handy
dandy ipad is heating up let them know
what we need right now
and what i need everybody to do is get
in the comments and tell us who you
think is winning mvp
on sunday i'm giving away hoodies and
i'm also giving away a jersey this round
connor
akeeb talk to us talk to the people bro
who do you like to win mvp
um
i i see i see them eyes man these aaron
donald odds man this great eye so it's
not a bad bet
and and i seen a beef as a player who
actually in this game seen him go get
two and a half sacks for his fumble
two force fumbles really so i mean he
went crazy but i think if you can get
two sacks
and one for his fumble or a lot of
pressure in two sacks and you kind of
disrupting the game yourself they might
give you mvp man i think
i think
imma go a d man i like that i like the
plus 1600 i think that's a good bet
i like to pick a key we've seen his
teammate von miller win this award
before so it wouldn't be that crazy
aaron donald probably gonna feast on
that bengals interior offensive line i'm
gonna look offense but i'm not gonna go
chalk here uh with one of the
quarterbacks because that's just it's
not gonna be that much fun right now i'm
gonna stick with odell i think ardell
has a big game if he can catch two
touchdowns in this one he's got a legit
shot at plus 2800 that's a that's more
than a bold bet at this point that's
that's a manless bet that's big time
juice so
i'll keep going with a.d plus 1600 i'm
going with odell beckham at plus 2800.
greg where are you looking on this mvp
odds board right now
hey hey everybody don't think too hard
you guys got the long shots i'm going to
be the chalk eating weasel and i'm not
going to be mad at it because the mvp is
a quarterback's award give me my staffer
plus 100. give me my staffer plus 100
man i'm taking that one to the bank
go get it staffer why not
why not but let me hop into these
comments man let me hop into these
comments because i'm giving away i'm
giving away hoodies and a jersey
i see
i see uh maxwell rexella in the comments
uh in the comments shout out to you maxo
rexel saying heads uh
m kent 93 says aaron donald is a luck
three sacks shout out to you m kent you
were walking away with the hoodie uh you
see k walker right there k walker also
has a.d with the gift saying let's go
shout out to you k walker you're walking
away next one i say
uh connor i'm giving them the jersey i'm
giving them the jersey
king 12 right there king 12 defense wins
championships with aaron donald donald
so i guess we're rocking with aaron
donald morocco with a keys pick but also
you are walking away with a jersey of
your choice i'm not gonna lie keep they
the comments you y'all got me over here
thinking about the 80 pick man it's
looking i mean he start right in front
of him he start like
two feet away from burro every play man
so i
hey i just i just feel this energy
you're gonna be on some different some
different stuff on sunday
yeah
yeah we saw what jeffrey simmons did to
that line so that would not be crazy all
right the comments like a.d mckee likes
a.d
i think he's making me and greg think
about an a.d pick as well but we got to
move on and talk about the guy that he
will be chasing and we're looking at the
quarterback head-to-head passing yards
matchup we're diving into props we'll
get to the over unders later but let's
look at boro and stafford right now this
one's simple guys barrow is the plus
money here to have more passing yards
staffer coming in at minus 120 he is the
favorite so
greg get him jumping right now let him
know what we need and i think it's time
to give away some more of those dk
dollars and not letting you take home
any of it
[Music]
man i wish i could take home 250 you
already know what i'm doing parlay but
anyway i need everybody to get in the
comments and tell me which quarterback
is throwing for more yards in the super
bowl if your pick matches my mana keep
to leave you are walking away
with 250 dk you could walk away not not
you are but you could walk away with 250
dk dollars i gotta pick you first i got
to pick you first
but yeah connor they walking away with
250.
all right let's get into it akeeb this
one's simple who's throwing for more
yards is it gonna be burrow who right
here get some plus money not bad or is
it gonna be the favorite in stafford at
minus 120
i'm gonna go borrow man i think the rams
have a a dog day on the ground i think
they they run the heck out to football
they get up early and i think uh
burro gotta turn into cool joe stay calm
joe see in the pocket throw the ball
around people have to throw the ball to
come back in the game so i think he
throw for more yards
all right greg the comments riding with
the key
or are they going with the favorite in
stafford
let me see man let me see i'm in the
comments let me make sure i get to the
to the new comments at the bottom
i got kate hart uh oh k heart 22 says
joe burrow
uh
shout out to you k heart
you know what k hurt
why not you're walking away with the 250
eight dollars that simple that fast that
quick k heart shout out to you
sometimes that's all you got to do get
your pick in leave the comment walk away
and you might come home with 250 dk
dollars all right and be sure to check
out draftkings every afternoon leading
up to the super bowl they are offering a
new big game super boost and these have
been crazy yesterday yesterday it was
cooper cup anytime touchdown score that
was boosted today tonight right now as
we're doing the show and do not walk
away you could do it after the show joe
burrow to throw over two touchdown
passes boosted to plus money plus 100
for boro to throw two touchdowns and the
daily super booths are only available
between six and nine pm eastern so you
will have some time at the end of this
but get on draftkings uh now through
saturday and take advantage of those
boosts alright let's move on next up is
the over under props i teased it before
now we're getting into it sometimes
these are simple fellas it's just points
right here over under is set at a 48 and
a half total we got touchdown passes
between both teams at three and a half
total touchdowns at five and a half
total turnovers interceptions and
fumbles not just interceptions at two
and a half we got a lot of good over
under props for this year's super bowl
so greg the audience has seen the board
you're tapped in with the comments how
did they take home a jersey right now
what i need everybody to do is get in
the comments and tell me if there will
if the over if there's going to be over
or under 48 and a half points in the
super bowl on
sunday i'm giving away hoodies and i'm
also giving away a jersey connor
all right let's get into this point
total right here sitting at 48 and a
half pretty steep in the grand scheme of
things this is no joke this point total
of keeb i think we got a shootout on our
hands and this goes over or you like the
under in this one
i said i think the defense come out hot
man they get it going slow i think you
pick up but i don't know if it's going
to end up
30 to 20 i don't know if we get there
yeah i'm saying i see a mid 20s to high
teens yeah i'm saying so i'm gonna go
under
yeah i'm with you all the way aki i
think listen i've been riding unders
most of the year uh it's been a pretty
good formula i think people get points
happy they root for points so they think
the over and in this postseason we've
had the defensive show out for the most
part we've got plenty of games that have
gone under so
when you look at this one from me i'm
with you under 48 and a half greg you're
making it to reena rowe right here you
rolling with the under are you thinking
we got a shootout on our hands for this
super
bowl my heart is telling me the under
but my mind and i'm gonna go with my
mind is saying take the over we know
about these offenses we do we know about
both of these offices and then the super
and the star power that each of them
have but i'm not saying i'm not saying
that it's not gonna come down to defense
because i do think i do think that it's
gonna come down to one maybe two
defensive plays towards the end
but i see this one being a shootout
connor i see this one being a shootout
of keep we got two quarterbacks good
offenses superstars on the offensive
side of the ball i see them putting up
numbers but let me get into
the comments because
i'm giving out hoodies and i'm giving
out a jersey and i want to know who am i
giving it out to and i see richie 21
richie 21 uh oh his comment went away
richie 21 says over 48 and a half points
and that is what i'm rocking with so
shout out to you richie you are walking
away with the hoodie uh enderman
enderman is in the comments says over
it's over shout out to enderman you're
walking away with the hoodie it's time
to give out this jersey
it's time to give out this jersey and i
see
guts six three says burrow two
touchdowns
i mean that's not what we're talking
about but just because you're engaged
you are walking away with a jersey i'm
giving it out to everybody connor
everybody is able to walk away with
jerseys 250 dk dollars hoodies whoever
just comment fill them comments up and
you could be walking away with a jersey
or a hoodie or 250 bk
greg the man liked the borough boost he
was listening he wasn't he's so locked
in two locked in uh and that's another
bonus we
we've partnered with draftings to offer
a dark horse odds boost on jamar chase
to rush listen to this fellas jamar
chase to rush over three and a half
yards you get up right now take a couple
steps that's all jamar chase needs and
it is at plus 120. that is a hell of a
boost so the question really is akib is
jamar chase gonna get some carries in
this one
jamar chase will get a play
where they put the ball straight in his
hands right connor
i don't know if it's gonna be a turn
around this way or is it gonna be the
quick pitch right in front of them you
know what i'm saying you know they from
that mcvay tree zack from that mcveigh
tree so they definitely got those plays
in
i gotta go with the overdose man we
talking three we talking four yards here
man huh hey
if you pick up a fumble
i don't know he it
seems like it's too easy so
i'm gonna go over that
i like it i'm with you all the way so
jamar chase over three and a half yards
boosted to plus 120. before we move on
to some of the yes or no props we're
going to have that board up pretty soon
greg you know what time it is it is dk
dollars time yet again let the comments
know what we got going on right now
hey i need everybody to get in the
comments and tell me how many total
turnovers
will there be on sunday
if your pick matches my mana key to
leads you are walking away or you could
possibly walk away with a chance at
winning 250 dk dollars
parlay that connor parlay that
that's the part it's always
that's the rules at this point all right
akib you know a thing or two about
making a play in a super bowl man you
know a thing or two about making a play
on the ball in the air we're asking you
right now
turnovers two and a half so we'll count
bumbles here this is not just
interceptions okay
how many turnovers you predict in this
one do you like the over do you think
this can get to three or these
quarterbacks that can get a little crazy
at times gonna keep this low
uh
i'd like to go over man i like both i
like both quarterbacks to throw a pick
so it's gonna be this two interceptions
and i think there's gonna be one fumble
in there somewhere so i'm gonna go three
man maybe two interceptions on one side
one interception on one side maybe one
and one and a and a fumble but i'm
definitely thinking three turnovers
greg which way the comments leaning
right now do they like the over for the
turnovers like akiv or are they going
under
and one of those lucky commenters is
going to take home the the parley
dollars is what we're going to call them
from now on yeah
i got ostino ostino says we rocking with
the defense take the over
that there it is there it is i'm not
there's no reason to keep going there's
no reason to give somebody else a hoodie
or jersey or anything because we're just
going to keep it short sweet and concise
ostino you're walking away with the 250
dk dollars you had the same
thing as my mana keep so there it is
connor yes sir that's simple all right
it's that simple let's get into these
yes or no props and fellas this is what
i like to call uh the maniac board at
this point this is where things get
entirely off the rails where you're kind
of you're saying you're hail maili hair
uh hail mary's and you're our fathers
and hoping that a safety to be scored at
plus 800 we got recovered onside kick at
plus 2500
these get really really nuts right here
greg what do the people need to do the
yes or no props to win a jersey right
now
what i need everybody that's watching
everybody that's here in the comments
drop your favorite yes or no prop
locks in the comments
giving away hoodies and i'm also giving
away a jersey this round connor
all right akiva i gotta ask you've seen
the book
do you like any of these
i do man i think i like a few of them uh
i initially like missed field goal miss
extra point
but then i thought about
the rams kicker gay and then i thought
about the young boy in the bengals and i
said i don't like that one no more right
so you got a pro bowler
and a guy who ain't missed yet in the
playoffs
but then uh
i like a two-point conversion man this
is 20 22 everybody going for two i like
the two-point conversion and i love the
last play ending on the deal
yeah i'm with you on the two-point
conversion i like that it's at plus 250
those are good odds and we know the rams
are not afraid of that we know zach
taylor coming from the mcveigh tree he's
not exactly that as well these are teams
that had they just had two weeks to
practice that the two-point package is
gonna be real in this one some kind of
scenario
so i i like that a lot of keeve i'm
going to take that one from you greg
what do you got going on and we're in
the comments at right now this is the
crazy board is anybody getting real nuts
and predicting a safety or an outside
kick
i'ma hop into the comments before i hop
into the comments connor i'm gonna just
drop just drop my lock or whatever i'ma
go with miss extra point miss field goal
this is the super bowl
butterflies are going to be flying we
have a youngster a youngster out there
kicking
we also have a veteran out there kicking
but butterflies will be flying and i'm
going with a miss field goal and it's
plus money
but let me hop into the cup yes sir and
a block and a block count is a miss
in a block count as a miss there it is a
keep a block count as a miss i'm in the
comments right now uh
i'm trying to find 100 okay here we go
deal precess 100 agree with akeeb
no you as you guys can see literally on
the screen the comments are jumping uh
they'll creep shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie uh
mgo blue 16 is in the comments saying no
safety uh i think that was a lot of
juice
uh
i'm giving away a jersey on this next
one i'm gonna give away the jersey on
the next one here we go i got h johnson
says two point conversion
deuces shout out to uh johnson one on
one you are walking away with a jersey
of your choice
all right the people have spoken uh for
the yes or no props but before we move
on i was able to catch up with
draftking's very own the legend of the
sports book johnny avello listen in
very happy to welcome back johnny velo
from the draftkings sports book johnny
obviously sports betting has gone live
in the state of states of louisiana and
new york this last month with a market
that is always always growing is this
the largest super bowl handle we will
ever see so far
well i can't speak for others connor but
it sure will be the biggest for dk
here's my explanatory memorandum as you
may say
at the beginning of the playoffs we had
a record-breaking handle year over year
and then in the following weeks as we
were down to less teams the handle still
continued to grow
so i'm looking for a big one here
yeah i would agree i think it's pretty
obvious it's going to be massive and
obviously along with that becomes an
extensive
prop menu draftkings has been phenomenal
offering a ton of different props
there's no doubt about that but which
prop if you had to pick just one or
maybe even two do you think will be the
most popular this super bowl
uh there are many
that i can uh put in the
you know most popular bucket
but i believe the first td score slash
anytime score will be among the most
widely bet
yeah we've seen a lot of action on that
all year which obviously is a little bit
of luck but also a little bit of skill
so
with that being said we went most
popular which one is the most difficult
to price overall
you know conor to be honest i don't
think anything is too difficult any
longer
uh you know when i was alone trying to
do these things it did i could tell you
there were a lot of them that were
difficult to price but we've got a good
sized team and a wealth of knowledge
among the trading the whole trading team
so things aren't that difficult any
longer
johnny you are a legend in this space
that's why we always love having you on
you've seen plenty of different super
bowls uh for good and bad reasons look
at a bad one here what's the worst super
bowl beat you've ever witnessed
uh oh by far
there is one that will always stand out
i know where you're going
this is a bad beat for the books and and
for me in particular so it's super bowl
48 it's at med light stadium
broncos are playing the seahawks so our
customer is not only betting there will
there be a safety in the game they're
betting
will the first score of the game be a
safety at 125 to 1.
so the broncos get the ball first and
after the touchback they're first and
ten at their own 20.
center manny ramirez hikes the ball over
peyton manning's head
and there you go safety we're stuck 200k
after the first play
now we recovered that day connor and
ended up making a few bucks but the
broncos did
losing the game 43-8
yeah that one was right in my backyard
so i remember it uh very very vividly
johnny avello from draftkings sportsbook
always great to have you on especially
during super bowl week
thank you great seeing you
a big thanks to my guy johnny talking
yeah he is an absolute legend in this
space uh thank you to him for an inside
look at this year's super bowl market
all right let's talk novelty props let's
keep this prop talk rolling let's take a
look let's fly the novelty props we got
the board here you know what it is it's
gatorade shower color on the winning
coach maybe the most popular
super bowl discussion when it comes to
betting but it gets always a little fun
down here we got a kick to hit the
uprights yes at plus 400 that is too low
for me fellas that seems a little bit
bold and then when things get real fun
and non-quarterback throw a touchdown
pass philly's special is what we're
thinking there yes at plus 1400 so
novelty props means nfl jersey giveaway
greg let him know what they got to do
here
what i need everybody to do is get in
the comments and tell me which gatorade
color will be poured on the winning
coach i'm giving away hoodies and i'm
also giving away a jersey this round
connor
all right let's talk what color gatorade
will be poured on the winning coach we
have an odds board with all of the
colors flavors whatever you want to call
it here orange plus 200 orange is the
favorite on the board followed by a
pretty even field of blue
clear as in water and then yellow or
green which is yellow gatorade for the
folks at home if you call it green
gatorade
i don't even know what to say
who decides this you've been in a super
bowl who picks the gatorade color
well i guess the the
training staff they
these decisions are made all the way in
training camp and i'm sure they put in a
huge order
uh whatever gatorade they're gonna use
for the year right so i mean
different teams got different gatorades
right whatever floats the trainers boats
right and then you got some guys some
players we put in special requests for
our getaway gatorades
but i don't know but uh before i seen
that list
i was kind of thinking orange i was
thinking i was gonna be orange but
i never want to go with the favorite
when in that situation i want to go with
the favorite
so i'm gonna go blue i'll go right right
i'll go to the second one i i'll go to
that plus 400 i think it was and uh and
go blue
i keep you are a man that does not make
the chalk picks and that is what i
respect about you i'm gonna follow here
and go a yellow gatorade right here so i
believe that came in around plus 450.
man i've seen a lot of orange gatorade
there's a reason it's at the top of the
board greg what are you looking at for
this one
[Music]
me right here i am a man that picked
chalk picks hopefully connor respects me
so with that being said i'm you're a man
that makes money orange i also have
have the color on orange so we're rock a
little orange
it's my favorite color
but let's see with the people let's see
what the people are talking about i'm in
the handy dandy ipad uh looking
for takes to give away hoodies and i'm
also giving away a jersey this round i
see dan dan duvall 54 is in the comments
rocking with purple shout out to you
duval 54 you are walking away with i'll
give you a jersey you gave us a gift
you're walking away with a jersey i'm
gonna give away two hoodies here connor
real quick i got officially goats red is
the best color so that's where it is
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie
and of course you know i had to see
somebody that had my pick jojo473454
orange bengals lock so there it is
there it is everybody that i've
mentioned you either walk into a hoodie
or a jersey
jojo uh wants that parlay money he wants
to parlay the gatorade color and a
bengals lock all right get on draftkings
bet the novelty props we've had our fun
with the props we've looked at
everything yes or no we've looked at the
over unders we've looked at the
novelties the coin toss
guys we gotta pick who's gonna win the
game at some point this is what it comes
down to somebody's gotta take home the
lombardi trophy and that means
somebody's gotta take home this iphone
13. it is the grand prize and giveaway
if you've hung around long enough you
have a chance right now to take home the
iphone so let's bring up the current
championship odds it is down to two
teams and you know them well we got the
rams the favorite minus 200
we got the bengals the underdog but only
at plus 170 not that crazy of a gap here
greg these people are chomping right now
for this iphone tell them what they need
to do
i need everybody and i mean everybody to
get in the comments and drop your lock
to win the super bowl if your pick
matches my man to keep to lead
you could be walking away with that
iphone 13 that i don't have
that a keep said that he don't got but
conor mcgregor around town is
not chad no not chet of course the nfl
legend not chet but connor word around
town right around town is you already
got one bro like
is that true
it is true and i'm going to be paying
this thing off for a long long time many
many months so you want to win it right
now okay you don't want to be like me
looking at your bill every month and
going yeah i just had to get a new phone
and i didn't want one i got bullied into
it i got made fun of everywhere i went
with my iphone eight so it was time i
paid the price we're getting both you
was dude
yeah i was re i was getting really sad
around these parts so all right akib
we're going to give the audience some
time to get into the comments and try to
win this phone so they're not like me
paying it off for a while i'll jump in
and make my prediction right here
fellas i
hate to do it but i'm rolling with the
favorite in the rams i think the
hourglass is finally emptied out on the
bengals magic i think you watch their
interior offensive line on tape and it's
amazing they made it this far jeffrey
simmons on the titans he had his way he
could have done anything and i know
burroughs got magic i get it but you
heard akiv earlier aaron donald has a
legitimate chance to be the mvp of this
game i think he dominates i think they
got the weapons to tear apart that zone
defense and if their time comes where
they do go man i don't think they can
run with cooper cup i don't think they
can run with odell beckham so i know
it's minus 200 it's not that fun i'm
rolling with the rams greg i am very
curious to get your take because
you got a little bit of vendetta against
this team rightly so but i know you also
make your picks with your brain not your
fandom
yeah this one this one this one's tough
connor i'm not gonna lie this one
actually hurts for me to say but i'm a
realist man i am a realist i was
actually at the game last week i was
decked out a key but i had niner hat on
niner jersey niner beads you know i was
decked out in my gear but but we did not
pull it off against this rams team
and it's hard for me to say it's real
hard for me to say but i'm just going to
say it i think this i think the los
angeles rams is going to get it done
they have what it takes they have the
superstars intact on the defensive side
of the ball and the offensive side of
the ball they have a good quarterback
and like we said we said at the
beginning of the show akeeb said it
connor you said it we're all surprised
that the bengals are here we're we're
all surprised that they're here i was
surprised that they beat uh kansas city
in kansas city so
i'm rocking with the rams man i'm
rocking with the rams and they're at
home mckeep so it's like it's a home
game in cali they sleeping in their own
beds come on man it's it's written up
for the rams to win in my opinion
all right i'm rolling with the rams
we got greg to roll with the rams you
understand how hard that is to do
akib i don't know if you remember the
last time you were on this show
was what is today okay
it was august it was you and we had
vince young we had vy on the show
remember futures
we were talking all kinds of preseason
bets
and you gave us a pick to win it all
let's take a look
you know i like to pick up that paper
man so look i always i'ma pick a dark
horse who really really got a chance you
know i'm saying so i'm gonna go with the
best defense in the league baby i'm
gonna go with the rams stanford coming
to town
if he catch fire and that defense do
what they supposed to do man that's a
that's that's a great bet plus what is
plus 1400 come on now
plus 1400.
he gave he gave it to you
in august rams plus 1400.
i don't even i can't believe i even have
to ask this but akib are you sticking
with your august pick are the rams
winning the super bowl
i mean why i called him the best defense
way back and what was that august that's
before five damn that's before my
brother went over there man i'll find
miller over there so they really even
cranked up even more
uh i gotta ride with the rams man i'ma
ride with the rams uh
they hungry man i look at the vets over
there
they hungry man aaron donald big wit
odell stafford man i just think they got
the right group of vets
who hungry they gonna they gonna lead
the charge man and
it's gonna be that effort i think the
the more hungry team play with just a
little more effort in the super bowl
that get them over the top and
last time a a team played a super bowl
at the house
they won easily so hey
y'all's out of trouble
that travels big
the bugs ain't have to travel back they
serve the chiefs man so hey
i like them to come out with the energy
i like it to really be a home game for
them guys
i'm wrong with the rams
all right greg you got to give away that
iphone at some point i'm sorry i'm not
gonna let you uh yeah i would let you
keep it but they're not gonna let us
take that phone so you gotta give it
get rid of it don't tell everybody what
i was trying to do man you know i was
trying to hold on to it impossible
make up make the quick bleach report
account and give myself the iphone but
uh
i'm in the comments right now man i'm in
the comments i see
okay the comments want to jump they're
going i see uh the lord's
apprentice says rams by 11
lock it up and he's got the flex on them
my man scotty shout out to you scotty he
like my man vy said he likes that uh
visca manny says flex on him as well got
the rams all right here we go big mike
says
rams win iphone win please oh oh there
it is right there
uh
all right but here we go here we go we
got
w trammell
saying august locks lock them rams in
not w tremolo i don't think that that's
gonna win it but here we go we got
e-money right here rams are winning this
one they are favorite for a reason they
got the best wide receiver in the league
cup the defense donald ramsey they also
playing at home rams are winning this
one g money i need this iphone my man ae
money218 guess what we are blessing you
my man you said you need the iphone
so greg is gonna deliver we are giving
you the iphone 13.
hopefully the rams really come through
and win this for us we are rocking with
you we are all on the rams so let's go
man we just gave my man an iphone 13. i
got to get to the store uh i got to get
to the store keith i got to go get me
one man
part of the family
why they do all my phone shopping wifey
i need to upgrade baby what's up come on
oh man the burner accounts running real
good right now or they should have been
but shout out to e-money taking home the
iphone 13.
speaking of akeeb's pick e-money rolling
with the key
i know one other person that's hoping
akibs rams do win the super bowl that's
our friend million dollar
marco who basically has a million
dollars on the line with the future
ticket riding on the rams it's simple my
man right here he bet a little over a
hundred k
on the rams and you see it right there
you see the date october 22nd he bet on
those rams at plus 850 to win the super
bowl not make the super bowl to win the
super bowl and because of that
he could take home over a million
dollars over 1.1 million dollars akeeb
the cash out is 600 000. he can walk
away right now with half a million
dollar profit half a million profit
would you let this ride would you hit
the cash out button no cowards on this
show we don't do that do you hedge it
what would your plane be here
oh connor
it's going to be hard for me to not hit
that cash out benny i'm saying
500 bands
we talking 500 bands here but
we is in the betting world right
this is beach report slash i mean mixed
with little draft kings right
keep the money on the table baby we
almost there baby we ain't stopping
early it's something i'm low
hey keep the money on the table baby we
got to pick up with him
all right you heard him
and we want to hear you everyone tell
marco what you think he should do
i think he should listen to akeeb
honestly and tune in to million dollar
marco's big game parlay friday at 6
eastern time in bleacher report f good
luck man i would be sweating marco will
be deciding how to play his future and
we'll be giving out more hoodies more
prizes to the best comments fellas
that's a wrap congrats to the winners
congrats and thank you to the commenters
and a special thanks to our guy akib to
leave for joining the show keith man
it's been great having you on
thanks guys man i always enjoy this man
i'm i'm i'm done playing so i get to get
into this betting world hey man i i
better calm down man cause i'm i'm
hitting right now
keep those good vibes going all right
everyone get in and check out you saw
him here we got custom props there's
draftkings promos they're insane right
here jamar chase three and a half
rushing yards boosted to plus 20. joe
burrow clocks ticking right now but you
still got two hours on the eastern time
zone for plus 100 for two touchdowns the
million dollar giveaway the no score
first drive booster we got everything so
on that note let's get out of here enjoy
your week enjoy your weekend everybody
good luck with all of your tickets greg
and i'll see you sunday for a special
super bowl squad ride at 11 a.m eastern
sunday morning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you